Hello,
hello, hello, welcome in.
Hello, YouTube.
Hello, hello, hello.
How are you doing?
I'm doing great.
How are you guys doing?
Hello.
Yes, yes, yes.
Today we are...
Today we are... we are business owners, baby.
Business owners Hello, Minto Tadayima Tadayima Hey Minto,
long time no see you, hope you're having a good Sunday so
far Did you move goal?
Okay, also congrats to you and Phoebe Chan On getting cast
in the school days, English stuff Thank you Cold and stinky
Nice bow Minto Minsunday Minsunday Misunday Misunday like
you're looking especially cute today my dog is excited to
collect capsules yes well we are we are not collecting the
capsules i suppose we are we are selling them this i'm sorry
does this say 4 000 yen to do the thing are we scamming
people this one is 1 350 yen this is 800 yen these are
ridiculous prices i think we will be scamming many many
people probably congrats on getting a grow with school days
remastered thank you we got a chance to review the family
tree yes many things have happened this weekend huh where um
oh my goodness started out anime weekend anime weekend anime
anime exebo weekend with uh fantastic reality we were backup
dancers for for mataw doing some ultra cool parapara.
And then, and then, and then we did meet and greets
together.
And then there was a sloppy sisters panel.
And then there was a dookie dookie rewind where I got to
perform with the sloppy sisters.
And that was so much fun too.
And then the whole poly densities were so scrungly.
We become the tourist traps.
Yes.
All right.
Thank you for the pink.
It was nice to say hi yesterday.
Sorry for getting Phoebe and Vicky on 6-7.
That's fine.
I'm starting a move Tuesday for a new job.
Can I get a good luck?
Good luck.
Oh, my goodness.
May all your gotcha roles be blessed today, fellow Aibu.
Please come home, Yae Amiko.
I'm blessing your roles.
And then, at the end of last night, at the Jast panel at
Anime Expo, they announced that they are doing a remaster of
the school days game.
And somehow, I'm in it.
That was the most bizarre.
That was a crazy email to receive.
That was a very...
That was a very interesting email.
I was like, they were like, we would like you to audition
for School Days dub.
And I was like, okay.
Okay.
That one day that I was late for the Mecha Camellion collab.
That's what I was doing.
That's what my NDA was.
is I was recording my life.
So now I can tell you all.
I think I said that you guys would find out sooner rather
than later.
Yeah, I'm not a very big role.
I am a bully.
I'm a bully girl.
It was really fun recording it, honestly.
I don't have so much voice acting experience.
uh they were very nice it was very fun um no i have no age
scenes so they kind of were like they were like we probably
think you don't want to do age scenes in case you do we
listed the characters that do have age scenes
but no i'm i'm safe baby i'm safe You're amazing at the
concerts, Amito!
Love the panel and congrats on the roll.
Thank you!
The concerts are so fun!
It was really fun.
One of... What... What... What... The... The...
Spice Girls.
It's really fun singing that with my friends.
And...
And then, of course, I write sins, not tragedies.
um that line there was one line in it was what a shame the
poor bride or wait what a shame the poor groom's bride wait
i can't even why my brain is so scrambled you know that one
but i ad-libbed i said dokey bird um i ad-libbed i ad-libbed
it yeah it was fun meeting right anime expo me and greet
hashtag free super Yeah!
I mean, it's not, but...
You still pay it for it.
You're paying for it!
I've avoided school days for years because it just wasn't
for me, but now we're going for it.
It was fun because every time, like, I would have to see
Makoto's face...
Have you guys played the visual novel?
It's like...
It's like a...
It's kind of...
It would stress me out when I would play it.
because it's one of those where like you have to make an
option.
No!
Oh my gosh!
Oh my gosh.
It's like almost fully animated, right?
And so it kind of, you know, it looks like the anime.
It's not the anime.
We are in the game.
But, um, uh, what was it?
Uh, when you are making a decision, it's one of those like
countdown things.
It would stress, it would make, it would stress me out.
When I, I played it, oh, my gosh oh my gosh probably like i
mean over a decade ago now from so
yeah it's like a qte it's like a qte so just a little
warning just a little heads up on that but uh it was one of
those types of games i think at the time i think at the time
when i played it it was like my first time play a game like
that too so i was like what is there i was like
what sakura wars had the same thing oh really now uh but
also if you do play go in ready to hate makoto when we were
recording it anytime i would have to see makoto's face we
like uh the casting director and the sound engineer we would
be like the sound engineer would like bring up pictures of
makoto he's the main character by the way he is he he he's
so terrible here she would bring up a picture of him and
then like a truck and pretend to hit him with the you know
things like this if you go in uh just know it's you're in
for a wild ride he's the dad okay don't oh man yeah like
half the town is like related the dad like half the city is
like
never look up the family tree the dad has gotten around
it's it's funny um don't don't go in don't go in being like
oh yeah i'm ready for sexy time i mean maybe but i wonder if
we get to unlock a secret nice bow ending if we make the
right choice thank you guys for the super chat so you're
saying we can get bullied by minto well yeah i'm bullying
like katsura i'm like you're amazing oh thank you yes yes
sorry i'm going through the super chest that i missed but
yes thank you thank you
i would not i mean you could self-insert if you want I'm not
judging.
But Makoto is like such a stinker.
But that's so funny because for the longest time, Makoto
characters in media that I would like consume, they would
all be so terrible.
It ruined the name for me for a while.
But yeah, it was a busy weekend.
It was so busy.
Oh, wow.
I can't believe.
That I am even, you know, any character in a...
The fact that a school day's remaster dub exists is...
I could have never believed it.
Ten years ago, I would have never believed.
I would laugh on your face.
This is why I was a Higurashi kid.
I believe it was mostly just psycho murder time and not a
family tree shaped like a fishing net.
There's just something...
I don't know.
School days is a classic.
You know?
I'm LARPing, please bully me.
LARPing?
I'm an actress.
I'm not role playing.
I'm a method actress.
I'm super excited for you to be the new voice of Rance.
On the opposite, my first Makoto was Makoto Nanya.
Who's that?
When I look it up.
Oh!
Blaise Blue.
Mito's VA arc is gonna go hard.
I told you guys I was in my voice acting era!
Crazy!
I'm in my voice acting era!
The only visual novels I've played are The Letter and Saint
Maker.
Also seeing Uota to panic at the disco.
Thank you.
So proud of you for all your successes, Minto.
So excited to see you doing so much.
Thank you, Nexi!
Nice boat, Minto!
Nice boat.
Wow.
I don't know.
Like, it does really feel like late.
Like, this year it feels like I have peaked as an otaku for
sure.
Because, like, being able to be involved in any sort of
classics.
I don't know.
Like, I was in a Toho year.
Eurobeat.
That's a classic.
And then
Kara!
Thank you so much for the Hakusubu!
This is my first time on Superchat!
Ah, thank you!
I'm torn between cosplaying a Lolita or Jidai-K version of
Yua Smash!
Which would you like to see?
Oh, I would love to see both.
Maybe Jidai-K would be so cute.
It's kind of a style that I really like, but I don't think
it suits me, so I would really like see it though maybe if i
see you wearing it a jiraike if i see a jiraike of minto and
then i think oh maybe it will suit me and then maybe i could
wear outfit of jiraike in the future maybe car thank you so
much for the fat kid there
but um but there is a one other thing i have not that has
not been announced yet where it is my true i there's a
there's a few things i still have yet to be announced i i
don't know that i can't say but they're like to me true like
a peak as an otaku i cannot i cannot top this ear truly i
can't i've i've been holding one in for a while that i'm
like It should be announced in a couple months, though.
What's... It's July.
Oh my gosh, it's July!
Happy July, everybody!
Hamidou, I'm not larping and will be self-inserting as the
MC.
But only at the parts where Minito bullies me.
But more importantly, congratulations.
Thank you, Gapu.
She's voicing Daru.
Uh...
I'm voicing Daru.
I could never.
I love that guy too, but...
I don't want to voice Daru.
I went to marry Daru.
New voice of Snake.
Ew, that would be the worst.
I would actually, if I was given an opportunity for whatever
reason to voice Solid Snake in any official capacity, I
would decline.
Or I would accept and then hire David Hater to be in my
place.
You know?
Yeah, I respect it too much.
I respect.
I voiced Daru in a fandom.
I love Daru.
I love him so much.
Wow, your voice is spot on.
I wasn't aware you could sublet roles like that.
I don't even know if you can.
I don't know.
I would do it.
Would you play Rose?
Wait, that would be so fun.
That'd be so fun.
David Hater is Min Phantom a Solid Snake.
That's like that meme picture of like Revolver Ocelot,
Revolver Ocelot, Revolver Ocelot.
But yeah, I don't know.
Well, we'll see what the future has for more voice acting.
I'd like to get into more stuff.
It would be fun, I think, so.
It'd be fun, I think.
But yeah, it was a busy, busy weekend.
Busy Anime Expo.
If you went, I hope you had fun.
Hot, hot, hot.
I hope you guys have, if you had a long weekend this past
weekend, I hope you had a good long weekend.
But, yeah.
It's been a while since I've been able to catch a live
stream.
Hello!
I don't have a Bobo update today.
I've had a lot going on.
One of my dogs...
Oh my god!
She's miraculously...
Okay, okay, good.
Pitbull is stronger than SUV.
I hope...
I'm glad.
for that.
I'm very glad for that.
My goodness.
Look, you remind me so fun.
It was!
Steiner said that this was a silly announcement, but this is
awesome.
So happy you're moving up in the world, Vito.
Thank you, Blue Cherry.
It does feel silly.
It does.
I feel very out of place.
But I'm very honored.
I am very honored.
to have been given a role.
So.
Yes.
Yeah.
But shall we?
Gotcha capsule shop.
Look at this guy.
There's so many cats around here too.
I'm excited.
This I've heard is very much like the TCG.
TCG simulator but...
Whoa.
Whoa!
Is this...
This looks more like...
This looks more like Ikebukuro.
My store question mark?
Looks a little bit more like Ikebukuro in a sense, but...
I heard, yeah, I haven't played TCG's shop simulator, so
this will be...
be a first for me whoa oh i didn't know we were across the
street from from oh she's weaker than me
nice oh
i'll take one please look at these boy anime eyes anyo what
does that mean hey get in the bag buddy
Her eyes are like, Oh, Sumimase!
Oni-chan!
Could you please take my flyer for the Mead's Cafe?
Oh!
Come back, come back!
She's so aggressive with it.
She's not Kawaii Moe at all.
She's like, Hey, buddy, you want to come to my store?
What about you?
We're twinning over here.
Hey, buddy, getting back my store.
Why are they like that?
I don't cat all day here.
What is this?
A muscle girl cafe.
I'm obsessed with gotcha porn.
I love this game.
Oh, really?
I'm excited to try it out.
What do you have?
What are you?
What are you pitching?
I love taking flyers.
Oh, someone said the things that i collect i collect like
the what that is supposed to be gamers interesting they said
that the i collect like uh you know maid cafe um flyers and
things like that it's called ephemera three made coming soon
all right we got one made two made three made have you seen
in con mini no what is that what is that Congrats on the
concert and the P&S man!
I'm seeing my kamiyoshi succeed.
Josh Bo, thank you so much.
I don't want to gotcha that gal.
Am I steal my whole stuff?
No, no, she'll get...
She'll get...
What is this hat?
She'll get, um...
Addicted too.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no!
This cat doesn't...
This cat doesn't trust you yet.
we gotta name our store you guys I think my store question
mark is pretty good my store oh it won't let me do the
question mark no what should we do how yeah
I won't let me do a question mark minke's mementos that's
pretty good dynos and divas
minkies market that's pretty good minkies saucy jacks what's
like a thing for caps you know like something to do with
capsules though your store my store no our store
Wait, I have an idea.
Capsule.exe.
No!
It won't let me put a...
It won't let me put a dot.
No!
What the?
Was that the cat?
Are you okay?
This cat doesn't trust you yet.
own robotic center.
Oh.
Whoa.
I like a Boise Noi.
I'm locked at level 26.
I have to order advanced robots to automate your shop.
Wow.
I have a hundred million.
A lot of hundred.
A hundred thousand yen.
Robot fight club.
What's up?
Can we go to the club?
The club is not open yet.
I'll open at 9 p.m.
Okay.
Inconvenient is a cozy game about running a store in early
1990s, Japan.
I haven't tried it yet, but it looks good.
Also, there's gotcha.
Ah, okay.
Sounds interesting.
Happy July, Mintz, and Off-Kai Month, too.
Oh, my gosh.
Off-Kai Month!
Which means...
Legends and new Densetsu's first three.
3d live show will be happening soon oh what there's a second
cat a second cat has come to my store you guys saw luffy
okay hold on
oh uh let's see let's see we can do capsules anew we can
change it later buy different capsule packs from the capsule
order page capsule orders alright these are expensive oh I
guess we're buying a bunch of them right?
20 of them yeah okay that's fine Aegis frame series banana
bunch add to cart Chibi Sheba we can't get filled frenzy
yet.
Nippon Bites!
Go, go, rainbow heroes!
Nyanyan Meat Cafe!
All right, wait, oh, did I order them?
No.
Bye.
My goodness!
I'm still busy in LA, so just dropping by to say thank you
for the meet and greet with girls yesterday!
Now we are ready to segment as we are!
Thank- whoa, thank you for coming by to say hi boys.
Oh my goodness.
Hold on.
Turn down the volume a little bit there.
That was loud.
What do I do with this?
Throw?
Throw.
Get rid of?
How do I get rid of you?
Trash?
Trash it.
Oh wait!
There's some outside too.
F?
Oh.
You're right.
Oh it does say drop.
You're so right.
This box is not empty.
Oh.
My bad.
I don't recycle apparently We'll put all of our stuff
outside Nobody will come into my store Unless they really
love Sheba Oh we gotta do a price
Let's do 300 Oh whoa Oh 500 550
My first 1000 yen Wow Wow I can't do anything with it.
I think you'd like to point and click Broken Age.
It's a game with good game with voices like Elijah Wood and
Jack Black.
What the heck?
They are in everything, aren't they?
Oh, this is the Banana meme.
550.
Lights!
Jujutsu Kaisen?
We are open!
Man the counter.
Why am I checking people out?
They just put the money in here.
Alright everybody!
Welcome!
You love!
Gotcha!
It's rough being in...
Oh my god.
What are you getting?
Oh, money exchange.
Yes?
Oh, what do I do?
Fair price, she said.
what am i doing oh yes exchange amount 500 yen wait where's
the oh here
there you go good verb yes yes yes okay they tell me how oh
wait that's uh one yen oh there we go
gosh they say it's a fair price they say it's a fair price
they have have no idea 500 100 i have to realize i'm not
making this money you know what i mean click on the coin
drawer wait hold on i have a customer the game is sabotaging
me thank you yes
also giving them 500 yen coins is useless because you can't
put those in the machines Oh, click on the coin drawer of
the capsule machine.
Oh!
Cash!
Holy gyaru.
Some do take them.
I've never seen a single one.
What the?
She activated my ping pong and she didn't get anything.
I think the cats are scaring away my customers.
Everybody loves the She-Ball.
Yeah!
What'd you get?
Oh, he's back.
He's back.
Oh, yeah.
Yes?
More money?
Holy cow, dude.
I'm watching with great interest.
He's hooked.
Nice, nice, nice.
Oh, we gotta, uh, we gotta keep getting more things.
Let's, uh, let's order some more stuff maybe, right?
Um, maybe we'll do a banana bunch in here.
And another Aegis frame.
Oh, you're back too?
Yes?
Speaking of density 2, X is first 3D live, Legends and New.
And for those who don't already have a ticket, where might
one procure one?
All right, I have a streaming ticket.
Phil, thank you.
You can get one.
The Legends and New website.
That is something.
Thank you.
Yes, there are streaming tickets.
Can I get 40 quarters of this?
Oh.
Oh my god, are you good?
It's a family bar!
Oh, there's two... Oh, there's not two of them.
What the?
Your attention, please.
The train bound for Ueno and Ikebukuro will soon arrive on
track number two for your...
It's so loud.
It's so funny how much this does not look like Akihabara.
Oh shoot.
Sorry, my bud.
I wanted to go home.
Saitama.
Live Japanese by English.
No, that's actually the most realistic part about this.
Is that exactly, that is exactly what the, what the train
station sounds like.
Wait.
Oh good.
Okay, fix your machines with your screwdriver.
What's wrong with my...
What's wrong with my machines?
Advanced tools?
Magnets?
I have bills?
Wait, where are my...
Where are my tools?
Or you can hit it with a bamboo stick.
Hmm.
Wait, what's wrong with my thing?
Oh no, we need more!
Where's my...
Oh, where's my delivery?
What?
Excuse me, ma'am.
It's a very reasonable price.
Nobody has gotten these at all.
Oh, I never ordered it.
Did I?
Oh, you're right.
Well, we need more Shiva anyway.
These are selling, like, hotcakes.
This must be the Densetsu Say Daki, but time.
Blind.
What is it?
Wait.
Screwdriver under tools.
There's no...
There's only advanced tools.
Which does not have a screwdriver.
It has electric screwdriver.
Oh my goodness.
Why am I dividing it like this?
B for tools.
Oh, thank you guys.
Machine is fully repaired.
Okay.
Okay, alright.
Oh, put it away.
Very awesome.
Yes!
Hey, kid.
You're like...
You're like mechs.
My machine was about to fall apart.
But these things seem pretty unreliable.
I've had so many of them break on me.
They're like completely manual.
Or like, you know, there's no electric...
parts on it or anything so would you guys pay 550 yen for a
banana goose would you guys do that?
I think I would yeah yeah fully mechanical yeah yeah yeah
yeah oh I'm so sorry yes hand me the money
hand me your money I snatch it from you Why do they only go
for the Shiba?
Fix your machines with your screwdriver.
Okay, we're still in the same tutorial thing.
I wonder if I'm fully repaired.
Close the shutters.
Oh, it's 9 p.m.
I'm allowing one last customer to come in
experience this.
I need to adjust the price.
Let's see.
What is it suggested?
450.
Final offer.
We have some really wonky gotcha machines with crazy springs
for holding ribbons.
I animate LA and I dream of the day we could get new ones.
Holding ribbons.
Wait, what?
What is the suggested price for this guy?
550 6, 7 700 final offer
I like how it adjusts all of them that's very nice
1 million take it or leave it my electricity I haven't paid
my rent is $2,400 for anybody that doesn't that's like about
like 18 USD $18
Holy cow In the on the street What Hanna said Found I guess
frame series and everything else I wanted Perfect you didn't
buy that I know you didn't Cheeby Sheeby series exactly what
I wanted Great Everybody was happy My ratings off the charts
Wait Cheapy Sheep Series wasn't in stock.
Selection was limited.
I couldn't find Cheap Sheep Series.
Waste of time.
Takami, I'm coming to your house.
There's a one star.
Oh, you're cute.
Want to come in?
No.
This cat doesn't trust you yet.
How can I get them to trust me?
Maybe if I put out food and stuff.
The cat just ran into my store.
Hey, if you're gonna hiss at me, leave.
Oh, we're open?
I guess found doesn't need to mean bought.
Hello!
Welcome, welcome!
Welcome to my store!
Yeah, I know.
I'm right here.
They're all coming in already.
Wow.
It's 8.30 a.m.
This is also a...
extremely unrealistic part of this game because everybody
knows that all gotcha stores in Akiba open at like 11
freaking a.m.
so you're trying to get to the gotcha place to see if they
have any metal gear gotcha pawn before you have to head to
the airport and none of them are open I
know I know how it is yes
that's an interesting hypothetical you made up there
hypothetically why everything opens a late at your that's
what i'm saying bonnie everything opens so late and it's
also very funny because you'll find so many people like you
know they'll start their day early they'll have like a jet
lag and wake up so early but you can't do anything for so
long.
You can't do anything until like 10 a.m.
11 a.m.
It's so annoying.
I said, hi, Bonnie.
Thanks for dropping by.
Let's grab my cash.
Someone bought the banana.
Let's go.
Okay, good.
pack boxes in the on the back room shelves wait what do you
mean whoa whoa what is this robot fight club rules do not
talk about robot fight club do not talk about oh you do not
talk about robot fight club two robots to a fight one fight
at a time no humans in the ring if a robot shuts down the
fight is over fights go on as long as the batteries last if
this is your first robot fight club, you have to fight
orbit.
Wait, how do I put this down?
Oh, drop.
Bokusatsu Tensi?
Bissi?
Doku-do-chan?
Bokusatsu Tensi?
Doku-do-do-chan?
Sell your second hand items.
Wait, what did you mean by that?
Oh, it's like a Bick or something.
Awesome.
Nailed it.
A show looks unhinged.
I cosplayed Dokoro-chan a long, long time ago.
You can make a Dokoro-chan bat like this out of...
I made it.
I got a bat.
And then I, like, folded...
I, like, curved.
up pieces of paper I like twisted them you do not talk about
robot fight club
that show was absolutely unhinged I also had like a little
capsule toy of one of the characters but it was like so
you've heard of cast-off figures before right like the
figures that you can take off the clothes and things but she
was a cast-off but she was from a capsule toy right so like
she was itty-bitty and you would just like be able to peel
open the shirt and see the boob only a single one so you
couldn't see any more than than one boob it also wasn't
painted so like the figure itself was but uh the boob was
not painted you get one as a treat all you need truly wait
place filled capsule pack store boxes stay out of sight but
remain accessible so i gotta order some stuff is that what
they're saying feather frenzy license well i'll get more
shee because that's popular and a banana bunch i don't know
what do you want from me it's the only thing people are
buying
all right thank you so like this right
she's saying sheeb on purpose right you've never heard of it
being called a sheeb instead of like a sheeb i knew you say
a sheeb that's a lot of people say sheeb sheeb what's in
your shirt oh that's ma'am your bra is showing Can I order
stuff?
Oh, whoops.
Can I order stuff for the cats?
Uh, decorate.
Whoa!
Wait, what is this?
What is this?
Is it like a poster?
Oh.
Hello.
What is your allowance?
You're in here every day.
Poster's and stickers.
My coin storage is full.
I'm stealing it out of her hands.
Gotcha seller.
I'm going into battle and require your riskiest gotcha.
Otaku.
You cannot handle my riskiest gotcha.
Yippee!
Oh, we went from zero to level one.
Yay.
displays what we're gonna we're gonna make this place so
cute wait so now oh we can get 50 whoa i don't need so much
i feel stock supplies oh second hand wait this one is so
cute oh this one's so cute these are kind of pricey you know
let's buy the shelf i don't know what it does wait buy and
then there was other stuff right there was uh decorations
let's buy oh here let's see what it is i think it's a poster
though it's 500 yen thank
you oh it is a poster it is a poster it's so banana dog
banana knackle
let's just put it up right right here rotate it oh here like
that right there I guess
oh my gosh my shebe is a run out are you gonna give me a
don't give me a bad rating hold on no no no no no no I have
more oops wait Oops, wait, uh, wait, oops, wait, oops, wait,
oops, wait, oops, wait, oops, wait, I messed up, guys.
Oh, my coin is full.
People are actually getting these.
Oops.
Let's do...
We'll do the big orders then.
The big boy.
Open capsules and reveal figures.
Open capsules may contain figures at different rarities.
Wait, I can open my own capsules?
Since Sheeb is flying off the shelf.
Oh, I can take one.
Take a capsule.
Oh, never mind.
Okay, okay.
Can I get some tokens?
The new banana bunch just launched and I need that banana
dance.
Let's see, how do I do it?
Pull.
What's auto pull?
This thing is so ugly.
I don't want to claim it.
I don't claim this figure.
Epic Rare!
Angry Sheeb!
Oh my god!
Epic Rare!
I got an achievement for that.
even oh let's display our epic rare for market prices that 5
000 yen and this bozo for one single yen
5 000 yen epic versus one yen loser
i want to get some more decorations in here Let's see.
Buy and buy.
This thing is so ugly, though I don't want it in my store
anymore.
I don't really like it.
Abstract.
Wait, anime.
Oh, yes.
Who are you?
I don't even know.
Give me...
Oh, it touched.
Oh, my God.
Wait, the foreigners are going to go crazy for this.
Wait.
The foreign...
Nice pudding!
We could have some cars.
You guys?
Maneki...
Manga!
Anime and manga!
Masks.
Origami.
Patterns.
I don't know what these mean.
Pixel art.
Oh, this is Kawaii-es.
Kawaii AF, you guys.
This is Kawaii AF.
Garugamesh.
Oh my god.
Our...
Tokyo!
You're of the horse.
This place is gonna go hard.
Oh my god.
Certified product made in Japan.
They won't be able to resist.
Oh my god.
Every weeaboo out there!
Holy cow!
The weeaboo will smash the cat!
That's epic.
This is epic.
This one.
Unfortunately, they're just too popular.
Okay, anime girl.
Oh, yeah.
Wait, okay, now we decorate.
So it's some Itachi, Naruto, this is so yes
we're looking real hot topic right now everybody a kawaii
neko
this is the aesthetic this is the aesthetic here we'll put
it like there as a maximum larp what does that What if we
say we're Tokyo gacha?
Oh yeah, oh yeah.
And then they have to know.
This is a certified...
Wait.
I'm sorry.
It's a certified.
Oh no!
So far, our store is looking great though.
Real Japan capsule.
Okay, now they'll really be...
Let's try it!
Let's try a banana.
Actually, no.
I really want to try...
Wait, let me take my money.
Let's try this one.
Inspect.
Wait, how do I inspect it again?
Here we go.
Autopul.
I'm really curious what these are like.
Where does one go to get their certification?
Whoa!
Oh nice!
That one's sick.
Place figures on the display.
Yes, we are doing that.
Wait, this one's sick.
What's...
Uh...
3,000?
Nice.
Pick up your old gotcha machine and place it inside the Neko
parcel delivery station to sell it.
My old gotcha machine?
Like this one?
Oh, move?
It's that yellow station that's next to your store.
Oh, here.
It's a gurnum!
Our store is looking awesome, you guys.
Our store is looking so cool.
What do you mean I have to pay rent again today?
I paid it yesterday.
Alright.
We are...
It's 8 a.m.
Lovely day.
Akihabara!
Tadayima!
Oh, what is that?
Everything's fine?
Come here, cat.
No, just out of reach.
Just out of reach.
each maybe rent isn't a steal if it's daily yeah probably
not wait robot fight club opens at 9 p.m nothing renovate we
can get big bigger bigger oh we can do our walls i like the
blue
I think the red actually goes much better.
I hope we can get some real Sukoi wallpaper soon.
It's giving certified otaku store in the mall circa 2006.
It actually is!
Thank you for seeing my vision.
Look, these are killing me.
They're so freaking funny.
Alright, let's open my store.
Someone's gonna come buy these.
My first ever Nippon Ginkgo.
Oh my god.
Yoink.
Are you...
Wait a second.
Did you pay for that?
Oh.
Not today, pal!
Do, do, do, do, do, do, do, do, do, do, do, do, do, do, do,
do, do, do, do, do.
We got a runner.
He totally did not pay for the one yen statue.
He just took it.
Starting time to selling plastic mall ninja katanas because
if cannibalism happens here, I swear.
There's no way it could.
Uh-oh.
My tool.
Everybody never fear?
Okay.
They're 100% working machines.
Hello, Cat.
Okay, awesome.
I should probably start doing those like at night or
something, you know?
Why is nobody buying the banana?
What does everyone hate the banana for?
Come on, do it.
Please, sir, I'm out here selling newspapers, and I'd really
like a banana dancing banana.
Won't you take my money so I can exchange it for?
Please, sir, would you like a paper, a daily paper?
Why do you dress like that?
This place has the MGS tumblers, right?
Those weren't gotcha.
A little pricey.
Chill out, girl.
It's a banana.
Um.
Those are cream gims, which is not what we're doing.
Not what we're doing here.
Alright, what do we do?
Open capsules.
Let's open up a banana.
Oh.
Hello.
Whoa!
Oh, it's common.
I thought I was going to be, like, super epic.
Wait, where's my dancing banana?
It's my birthday today!
Mad Wing!
Happy birthday!
Hey!
Banana wall!
Yeah!
Oh!
We got dark banana!
Awesome!
Share an ad post.
Hello.
Oh, my shocked one came back for one yen because he did not
pay for it.
This one, I'm just gonna do suggested price and round up.
We're gonna round up, suggested price, round up.
Oh wait, it does have a round button, doesn't it?
No, no, no, no, 200, yeah, there we go.
All right, I probably need to, I wish I could see more
easily if these were running low or not.
Seems he returned it.
Good, because he sucked.
He was terrible and stole from me.
Um, let's get more Sheeb.
More banana.
I guess more Aegis Ring, too.
Let's just get everything.
Bye, bye, bye, bye, bye.
Reach level 2 to proceed.
Okay.
do this one too.
Sheen is full.
Hold on, I will serve you in one moment.
Oh, maybe people aren't buying Banana Bunch as much as I
thought they would be.
Oh, you would like him!
You're putting one yen on your credit card?
You don't have a single yen-y?
Thank you for your business.
that's like less than one cent times are tough no freaking
way what if I put more they wouldn't notice would they she
paid the 5,000 for that yeah I Amiko came home yeah let's go
She's buying the epic.
She's a real collector.
Oh, wait.
It's fine.
Okay, good.
And then we have more Sheebes here.
Good, because we just ran out in this machine.
Okay, good.
Alright.
Awesome.
Awesome, awesome, awesome.
Hello!
Aw, these school kids are such suckers, aren't they?
Oh.
It's so funny just seeing this stoic kid.
With like a duck.
He just slams.
He throws the duck on the counter and was like, I'll take
this guy, please.
Awesome.
Oh, yeah, baby.
Oh, you're back.
Oops.
Wait.
Oh, wait.
How did I get rid of it before?
Oh, remove.
There we go.
There.
She's an influencer.
Um.
What was I doing?
Oh, the ad post.
But it temporarily increases customer traffic.
We probably want to do that tomorrow.
right events and ads i don't know let's see oh i can't do it
yet until i'm at level two so oh okay that's why it says
reach level two to proceed nailed it yeah i'll take that
i'll take that oh yeah we did it oh we did it we can get a
new license oh yes hello you did not just see me jump over
my counter I'm like Tom Cruise I love her I love her I love
her I love her Why did he do all of that Why was he jumping
on Oprah's couch It's Satoshi He saw everything
He was going insane A bit expensive Yeah you're like five
years old You wouldn't know a good price If it bit you in
the butt Satoshi Maybe if you didn't leave home at 2, you'd
be fine.
Hag lore.
I feel like people know about this.
Oh wait, now we can do our...
Oh wait, no, we're about to...
Wait, spawn rate.
Yeah, it would be such a waste if we did it now, right?
But we do have a new wall.
I kind of like it.
Wait, it's taking my money every time!
No way!
It's taking my... I want you to buy it, but...
You don't get to keep it.
It was taking my money!
I was scared!
Yeah, we'll go to a robot club.
Can we go to the club?
Sure, hold on.
I'll come pick you up in front of your store.
Isn't it right here?
Hop in, loser.
Wait, how do I get in?
Oh, enter car.
The burnout!
My man, please!
What's going on?
Alright, guys.
Tokyo Drift!
Oh, the robots.
Place a bet?
Dang.
I can't lose.
We have a business.
Are you my friend to go home?
Not yet.
I gotta get an iced coffee.
Or Dodinku.
Alright.
Let's place a bet.
I'm all in on Rivet.
I believe.
Rivet!
Oh.
Go Rivet!
Oh, shoot.
Go!
Nice!
Yes!
Yes, I'm on fire, baby.
I'm on fire, baby.
Give me a bet.
Okay, uh, crank.
Crank.
Oh, shoot.
Don't let that honk out.
Look at his skinny legs.
Come on.
Oh, yeah.
Come on, crank.
Dodge it.
Oh.
Oh, one more hit.
Come on, Crack.
Yeah.
I'm on fire.
That was a rush.
It sucks to be you.
We learned nothing from Glottis.
That is kidding.
Thank you very much.
That was awesome.
Let's go home.
They look like they're in different weight classes.
They're robots.
They're robots!
They have no idea!
Alright.
Oh, yep, close the shutter.
Nice!
Got attacked by staff.
Absolutely terrible.
Yeah, because you stole from me.
Chibi-chib series was way too expensive for what you get.
I agree, actually.
I agree.
Yeah, it was actually pretty bad.
Winner!
Oh, years!
Time to spend 5,000 on Gachapon to get the Minto figure.
Dang it, gotta spend 5,000 more.
Dang it.
Wow.
Another day living the dream.
What the?
Are you going to school like that?
Where's your skirt?
Just out here in the booty shorts.
Isn't this the initial D car?
Why is it just play the convenience music?
It's so funny.
What's this?
why are the cats flying through the air what is this what
where what lines are these this is not the akihabara
akihabara has changed when cats fly all right let's make our
ad uh bubba bubba ad buy that was pretty expensive and let's
get these people coming in baby
the japan is known for flying cats i had no idea i had no
idea wait did i oh what was that what was that he was like
all right 16 okay
all right everybody's purchasing the repairs oh my gosh
thank you Oh my gosh, we almost lost Shiba Machine.
We almost lost Shiba Machine.
That was pretty bad.
That could have been diabolical.
The one's at the front.
Okay.
I guess I've never been...
Yeah, I've never been to Japan.
When...
Oh my gosh.
During Flying Cat season.
I guess I need to go back again even more so sorry I need to
go back again even more trips why are you making that
expression huh why are we acting this way it's a special
time of the year hello Jujutsu Kaizen a
little pricey well who's all these all these critics coming
in here all the sudden itadori yeah john jujutsu kaisa wait
is uh is that dr slump cute collecting my money was that 6
000 yeah and that's crazy
all right all right so what do we do to get to the next
level also right morning ratings okay we're three we're four
almost a five we're we're doing good we're doing fine um how
do i get to the next oh wait we can get feather friends you
know or are we at level two what level are we at oh we're
level two dang it just went to a gachapon store in little
tokyo while listening to your stream and got what i wanted
let's go wait why are they acting like this is this one too
expensive i guess we could have tried 650.
fair price they said maybe we'll actually get oh now go to
this
they're jumping in the air they're jumping for joy
Alright.
Wait a second, she did not pay for that!
Help!
Killing all the...
Killing all the thieves, Dokuro-chan!
Hmm.
Oh, wow, wow, wow, we're getting crazy.
crazy cash right now guys holy lots of achievements yeah for
hitting people and killing them i think we might need to do
another stock restock oh sheba sold out the rare one could
be in there i could have just put it back in let's buy some
more shebes capsule order level three oh my gosh and a car
what what was that a k-pop star has arrived oh my god oh my
god oh my god they're here oh my god they're here the k-pop
boys
the k-pop boys are here oh no oh my god oh my god they're oh
my god they're oh my god pot found it baby oh kia they're so
kakui oh kia they're making me so much money please come
back oh my god oh my god my stuff is all selling out oh my
gosh whoa whoa everybody wanted it banana banana bunch holy
cow excuse me
oh my gosh Okay.
Alright, we're fine.
Everything's good.
Oh, we're out of...
Oh, shoot.
I forgot to run this too.
I'm drowning in success.
I actually am.
There you go.
Oh, you want that.
Thank you.
200.
On the credit card, buddy.
You better.
We need...
Oh, whoops.
We need more Aegis.
And you know what?
I will just get another thing of Banana Bunch too.
about rush hour.
We're almost out of the Shiba already.
Holy cow!
Okay.
All right, hold on.
One second, one second!
This is all sold out so people will get really upset if I
don't have it.
All right, all right, all right.
They'll get mad, they'll get sad.
They'll rape my store.
They'll be like, this is the stinkiest store ever.
How
two cats give you luck you got to fill the bowls too oh but
i don't know it doesn't let me fill the bowls unless oh my
can oh i thought i had to buy it interesting oh oh shoot oh
shoot it's broken oh shoot it's broken six figures is the uh
wait uh what's my tool tool bait wait Let's go, hi!
Let me show...
Okay.
Broken!
I'm glad I already had it out.
Is another one broken?
Oh my gosh, why are they breaking all my machines?
Another one is broken?
Oh my gosh, oh my gosh.
Holy cow!
Why is all my stuff broken?
Is it because I went to...
Oh my gosh, it's because I forgot to fix everything.
I went to the robot club and I forgot to do it.
Shop owner of famous gotcha store, Marrakech beats
customers.
And I'd do it again, I would do it again.
Beat up.
Beat up the criminals.
No mercy.
Customers waiting.
Okay.
Alright, alright.
My door.
Hello.
Twins?
Or should I say...
Bow bow are you?
You want this?
See you guys.
There will always be some sucker.
Say it to my birthday, Salty Vaughn.
Happy birthday!
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday.
Dear Salty Vaughn, Happy birthday to you.
I don't think they're twins, they didn't leave together.
Wait, now we have cats, you guys!
Best store experience ever!
I only have nine left in here.
Alright.
We're gonna do some...
Oh my god, I'm gonna...
Manecki-Nekol.
Pet more cats to upgrade.
Manecki-Neki-Neko will boost your sale and fortune.
Whoa.
Alright, let's order some more Sheeb.
Let's order more everything, actually.
Wait, did I get it all?
No.
I'm gonna even order two of these.
Sheeb is very popular.
Look, we already...
Already went through a whole thing of them.
Alright.
Okay.
Okay, that's full.
So I'll just put all the... Oh, whoops.
Banana bunch together?
Oh, I thought that was Len.
Who?
I thought that was Len of Vocaloid Fame!
Who are you?
Oh, I didn't check this one.
We can check too.
It's Haley Jewel.
No, it could not be.
Don't even joke.
That was something so disgusting.
Repair.
I know, I know.
I'm working on it.
We're going through the list of...
We're now going to collect money.
Okay.
And then we repair.
Hello, baby.
Okay, nice, nice, nice.
We are also going to get some things of...
Let's auto-pull some.
Let's auto-pull five of the sheep.
This is going to be huge.
Oh.
Uncommon.
Ew, it's so ugly.
Who is...
It's a nerd.
Okay.
It's a nerd!
All right, starry eyes.
Oh, I leveled up!
We can finally, oh my gosh, you guys, we can get more stuff.
We can finally, oh, this guy again.
We can get the,
we can get a new franchise.
All right, nice.
went to oh because that girl i attacked her that's right
that's at one yen again my uncomments i feel should be at
the top but it won't let me move them actually so this guy
what's the suggested price okay 2000 thank you suggested
price dang 45 someone will buy it someone will buy suggested
2000 nice i'm a very shrewd business woman aim
at the figurines platform so you see the green ring right
click to remove it okay okay oh like that oh right oh i see
it thank you thank you so much i don't know oh there we go
there we go okay uh this one's tough there we go there nice.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh, I guess Tongao is also
we'll remove these two.
Put these at the bottom.
I can't believe that guy tried to steal a little figurine
that was 1 yen.
In fact, because of that,
market price goes up.
Alright, and then let's do some new You have to pay for it.
Customers are looking for this.
That's what it just said.
Your collection journey truly begins.
Pack initiate.
Okay, nice.
Let's do like five packs, five things, buy.
We'll get, what is this?
Oh, I think we need some more, huh?
We'll get two, buy, decorate.
Oh!
They're birds, by...
We're putting these guys to work in the middle of the night,
for sure.
Don't buy the wallpaper, it's a scam.
Wait, what is it?
Why is it giving me a little exclamation point?
Here.
Is there something else?
Oh, we can do a small display.
Huh, but it's so exp...
Well, I guess it's not as expensive as the shell, huh?
I need to move this.
Pick up.
Anime girl under the middle.
And pick you up.
And let's put my machines.
Right.
Stinking right there.
And another one.
Right there.
Oh, I guess I didn't have to pick that up.
Cool.
Uh.
Feathery friend.
Oh.
Uh.
Like right there.
It's a little haphazard, but don't mind it.
You.
Awesome.
Some in the back.
Cat likes me.
We got Monarchy Neko level 2.
Oh, look at the run!
Look at the run!
Did I miss a box I did?
Level 2 kitty buff?
Now I would go to the fight club.
But at the moment...
More like 250.
More like 300.
Let's do one.
Or five.
I would usually go to the robot club.
But because we are...
Or, uh, you know.
Oh, how cute!
Because we're starting a new item.
Oh, what?
This guy is, uh, common?
He looks so exciting, though.
I want to just start the next day.
You know?
A rare!
Guild wing!
Oh, my gosh.
I was looking for this guy.
First rare.
Luck is on your side.
He's cute.
What about this guy?
Oh.
Nice.
A squawkster.
Cool.
All right, we can put those up tomorrow after people buy
these.
I guess I have to refill it, though, because I bought my
own...
Oh.
Yes.
The cat likes me.
The cat...
Manaki Deco level 3!
We're going insane-o-style.
What's happening?
All right.
Everything should be good then.
And let's close the shutters.
Finish the day?
Get to the next day?
Yes.
Pay my bills.
My daily...
How much is that a month then?
If I paid $20 a day.
Five stars all around besides this person.
Kota, what was your issue?
What is your issue?
It means you gotta roll the metal upa!
If I do, people will die!
What the hell is your problem, lady?
Kitties!
Hi, Ken-chan.
Can you change the price to lower, buy the capsules, and
then raise it again when you open?
Oh, I won.
Actually, I think I get it at, like, base price.
Right?
I think.
all right
but it's also my money I just get it back yeah I just got
the money back thank you stop trying to make Insano style a
thing it'll never be a thing you're just jealous of my sick
lingo
you're just so jealous don't even don't even try to act like
you are better than me give yourself a shopkeeper discount
but i get the money back no can you buy more kpop star
visits oh wait actually let's do oh wait not that uh let's
do an ad we just started the day so i can hire staff oh i
have to unlock erica edica saito at level 28.
Her cashier skills go crazy.
Hello, alien child.
He says, I'm...
Oh, what are those kids?
Those, like, bug enthusiast kids in Pokemon?
He's like, I'm bug boy Joe.
I'm bug trainer Joe.
Where's Ryan when you need him?
I unironically use Insano style.
Is that not normal?
Mint is Insano style cute.
It's a trendy lingo island.
The bug catcher!
Hi, Minto.
I can expect you today just like always.
Thank you.
Why is my cat...
Who is messing with my cat?
Ken-chan.
And who are you?
Cat with no name.
Why does the cat have no...
where have you been a cat with no name do do do do do do do
do it's a cat with no name did it customer waiting oh pine
and say no style all the cats are not the cats the kids all
the kids are saying it oh oh oh oh bye and Insano style.
I wonder...
Whoa, we're at level 4 out of 5.
But like, what does it mean?
Pretty sure I heard the coolest influencer using Insano
style several times today.
You're...
Anyone who hates is just a hater.
I don't make the rules.
So it's the Maneke Neko.
My luck for people...
coming in or is it my luck for gotcha i wonder
the cats are saying it too how did you know this kid's back
a little weirdo i think you're i think your tank top is too
small for you buddy i think you might need to size up a
little you just had a growth spur huh
It's like an apron, yes.
The cats are in my store.
Ken-chan!
We can name the other one.
The other cat.
Oh, final level!
Maneki and Neko, final level.
My luck and my fortune.
The famous cats of...
Oh, nice.
Of Akihabara.
my tools my tool my tool?
Oh B I keep pressing T
Lucky cats gotcha luck stacks with the pull chance modifiers
when you spin from the machines oh I see wait what are we
out of Aegis?
Okay hold on one moment one moment sir I will be with you
and just why are you making that pose freak yes
yes do you think we'll start selling food and stuff here
coin storage is full I grab it oh yeah mechs are back in
baby everyone is pulling for them I'm here.
I'm waiting for you.
Hope everything's good in the hood.
It's good.
It's their pull ritual.
I don't think it is because they don't pull.
Oh yeah.
I like the little dance that they do.
It's so cute, actually.
Too expensive, bro.
What for the chickens?
Hello!
Yes, I can do this for you.
Yes, okay, I'll bring the chickens down to 200 or something.
Jeez, tough crowd.
I need the metal Upa.
All right.
All right, nice.
Give me all the money in here.
Very good.
Advanced tools.
We don't get these until so much later.
Holy cow.
But I'm feeling like maybe we get two more machines or
something, you know?
And we can place them here.
Time to pick this up.
Hmm.
because I think maybe another banana maybe I have to go
thank you Minto for the funny stream and congrats congrats
again for your video thank you Moe for you see you later
thank you thank you
hello he's got stars in his eyes yo yo We'll become a little
disillusioned one day, buddy.
Akatsuki.
Yeah, our place is looking sick.
Honestly, wait, were there any more decorations we could
get?
We got abstract.
Oh, alphabet!
I missed this.
Oh, no.
Level four, we're going to be able to unlock a bunch of cool
stuff, too.
Let's get a dragon.
Why not?
Maybe some fish.
What the?
Who is putting this in there?
shop i'm i don't even have food like i'm so confused we'll
do nice play nice play
oh where what is my doing oh japanese we'll do a car some
cars a nicky nickel
origami actually two of them what are the patterns they're
just they just look nice i guess pixel art oh yeah we got
the cat romantic we i think this is good this is good need a
minto on the wall yeah truly
good job kittens
can we get more certified certified I'm a I'm a certified
shop only only real real supplies here all right let's
restock gosh she was so popular honestly I think this
machine should also be sheeb let's order some more sheeb
nice I didn't notice many people buy our things today as
yesterday let's do our rare plastic bird wait suggested
price is 1200 exactly what i was thinking too the dragon we
need some more stuff here like right next to my cash oh yeah
i wonder why it's an mystery.
Nobody can explain it.
Oh yeah, oh yeah.
This is Tokyo Dorifto.
The cars are kissing.
Oh, I didn't say we're ready to thank you guys.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
We're playing sick.
A business game.
Nice play.
Origami.
This is a true Japan experience.
You get origami and you get Maneki Nekos.
And you get more origami.
Oh, nice.
Nice.
Wait, did I collect all the money in these?
I think so, yeah.
So let's repair.
Oh, I need to get more, I guess.
More origami.
I'm in gacha heaven.
Not yet.
We need some, like, anime girl gacha things, you know?
The cats are fighting outside.
Okay.
And you.
Though I'm going to have to repair these again.
after I, uh, try my luck.
Oh, there's only two left!
Oh, no!
Are you a new cat?
Oh, wait, no, you're not.
You're not a new cat.
The lighting made it look like a new cat.
Let's...
Buy some more stuff.
Add the cart.
Add to cart.
You have to spend money to make money, baby.
I think we have plenty of bananas.
Yeah, we have plenty of banana.
Feather frenzy, I'll restock.
Oh, those didn't do nearly as well as I thought they did.
Just kidding.
This one's pretty low.
No way.
Alright, more Aegis.
Can we roll for Densetsu figures here?
Absolutely.
If you've got the money, we've got the power.
Oh, okay, it is full.
Well, easy.
Nice.
Alright, nice.
Alright, and then one last box.
Of bird frenzy.
go nearly as hard as i thought it would but we can do let's
do polls on this one
i previously ordered eight of something in different colors
and didn't get what i wanted the ninth showed up today and
it works for what i need wait what that works though nice
a rare a rare oh it looks good the gv 21 soul braver nice
common all right
rare oh that guy's kind of pricey no
oh so many dupes so many dupes Oops, uh, all right.
Well, we have stuff.
Okay, I'll bring these down to, like, 270.
And this guy can go to, like, 19.
We just gotta be patient, though.
People will buy them.
Blue.
You love rare plastic, me too.
I think we did everything then.
Cat likes me.
I love the cat.
Shall we go to Robot Fight Club?
Can we go to the club?
What took you so long?
Don't forget the ad for the next day.
What do you mean?
Because I did the ad yesterday.
Or for today, I guess.
Let's bet on...
Ooh.
A reward for Spark is more.
Oh.
Fight!
Go Spark.
Spark?
Spark, you're the man.
You're the robot.
You're the machine.
You're the nuts and bolts.
You are!
You're it!
Spark!
Stream sparks?
Yeah, baby!
Hatsune Miku.
Hatsune Miku, what are you doing here?
You can tell, gosh, you can see it in her eyes.
She can't get enough of this.
The people are standing on the cars and headbanging.
There's nothing right going on in here.
This is a world of debauchery.
I'm standing on the cars, too.
All right, let's place our bets, guys.
We're too good at this, honestly.
I'm gonna...
I bet on...
Let's bet on Bolt.
Oh, yeah!
Bolt packs a punch, baby!
One more!
Yeah!
Oh, we're all in heels!
You're so sexy!
okay not sexy when he's oh yeah holy cow you guys we're like
making so much money from being here i mean i know you have
to spend the money to make the money but crank was like
crank was having a bad time this cat is like reverse
moonwalking to me wait i think my rating went down you guys
why wait three oh yeah we're almost four stars okay never
mind my rating went up checkout line was way too long took
forever banana bunch is too expensive should I bring it down
a little
okay that should be good good night everybody
unhappy one person dang
my profits
kitties kitties look how cute look how cute you come
trotting over alright it's 8 a.m let's do this
that uneven number would get a bad review for me what are
you talking about I literally wait
it wouldn't let me wait oh I wait wait Oh no, I made it more
expensive.
Wait, what was it before?
Uh-oh, guys.
Uh-oh.
Suggested?
Four.
Oh, shoot.
I don't...
It was 450?
Okay, we'll do 440 then.
It won't let me do a...
What?
Okay, we have to do 400 then.
Wait, this is so lame.
Did someone walk out?
Someone took something and walked out.
I missed it!
Oh no, wait, she's buying both of them.
Okay, I was scared for a second.
Thank you!
Is round a toggle?
I'm not quite sure.
My rating went to 4.4 though, guys.
This is huge.
Suggested price.
What?
oh
yes of course the sucker the suckers have arrived everybody
and let's oh whatnot capsule order my bad let's do an ad
here we go hopefully we can get some kpop stars in here yes
oh no my cat rating went down okay there we go
maybe i should make this like a little more expensive like
that i mean why not we'll do flare break suggested
and then you suggested coin storage is full not that one
though all right I'll start grabbing money.
The money is flowing.
Honestly, they make this job look so easy.
They make this job look crazy easy.
Scalper pricing.
I hate scalpers as much as the next person, but I'm running
a business here.
If it's my business, I can do no wrong.
If it's my business, I will.
Make money.
Make the big prices.
Is this a game?
Is this a game to you?
Is my store a game to you?
You say this is a game?
This is...
This is my shrewd business tactics.
Are we being...
Are we serious right now?
Are
we for real?
is minto becoming a scalper i'm becoming a shrewd
businesswoman i am becoming a girl boss i am running this
business i'm in the heart of akihabara you know how many
other places i have to compete with this is this is my
afterlife you aren't gonna tell me that something worth
720 yen.
It can't be priced at 1,200 yen.
Actually, that was one of the more reasonable prices.
Oh my gosh, wait, we get another license.
Guys, this is huge.
This is huge.
You want that little guy?
Oh, uh, change 50 yen.
He bowed at me.
What a polite citizen.
More gotcha machine!
Oh, what's happening to the cats?
What's happening to the cats?
Coin storage full.
Everyone wants banana.
The banana stonks are going crazy.
They're jumping in the joy saying, I mean jumping for joys
and banana banana banana We must get more banana Everybody
is going bananas and I am going profits No, we got k-pops.
Oh shoot.
We got k-pops guys Uh, everybody restock restock And what
the mca.
I don't pay for songs in my store Oh, please don't play that
in my place.
Oh my god.
It's ready for chaos All right k-pop's can you please oh
machine is full okay cool banana bunch More like banana buy
a bunch of gotcha.
That's right.
That's right
Banana buy so much My screwdriver?
I repaired stuff before.
It's fine.
We're still good.
I'm glad that seemingly repairing thing is repairing stuff
is free.
All right.
Nice.
Oh, hello.
Sorry.
It took so long.
A repair machine is broken.
We'll get in a second.
We have another bird thing, so it's fine.
there you go all right tool tool all
right take the money take the money take the money take the
money take the money take the money take the money all right
all right i really want to order the gotcha stuff the new
things so i'm kind of like
Cat likes me.
Oh, I see the heart is like the heart in the top left is
showing me, I think, the time until the K-pop buff wears
off.
Oh, we're sold out.
We're sold out.
Let's go.
Well, this is fine.
It's almost the end of the day, so we'll be able to...
Customer's waiting!
Machine is broken!
Oh, how much is that one?
5,000!
Pleasure doing business with you.
Two broken machines.
Uh-oh.
Oops.
Wait, how do I return it?
Remove?
There we go.
Ah!
She kind of looked like me.
What do you mean?
are borked.
Oh, I need better machines.
I need better machines.
I'm taking care.
I'm keeping this whole area afloat.
I'm feeding the cats.
I'm doing everything.
It's almost the end of the day.
Uh, 500.
Thank you.
Compared to the movie rental game, how are you liking it?
Gotcha.
I'm liking this one a lot.
It's definitely different and similar in many ways.
But nothing is like, you know.
Oh, I don't like this.
So.
Oh, broken!
That's fine.
We need to break.
Or we need to not break.
We need to fix all these anyway.
Hello?
It says it's fully repaired.
I think my game also broke.
broke the movie names that yeah the movie names are really
funny i do like seeing the different gotcha though i think
they're kind of fun i
like seeing all the different gotcha stuff it's pretty fun
to me too this this tickles my weeb brain you know there we
go there we go and now we can buy new we can buy new yes i
want when we can buy new machines because these are stinko
these are pretty bad oh collect my money okay yeah they do
break super fast right all right mystic spellbound customers
are looking for this we'll buy three boxes feather frenzy i
think we still have a good amount of oh we can buy we can
buy some more we'll buy feather frenzy box and aegas frame
box actually one more buy let's buy some more decorations oh
wait the mystic spell powder anime girls oh my god it's it's
it's so ha it's happening it's happening it's happening
there we go what else can we abstract is i don't want that i
don't want that in my store we could buy more anime more
clouds dragons fish food i don't even have food
more cars more cars
I want more origami.
Pixel art.
Oh, cat with headphones.
Huge.
Hmm.
I can't wait to get the photo realistic Sakura.
Not a huge fan of the Sumos.
Certified.
They have to know we're absolutely certified.
Year of the Horse.
Japanese.
Yeah, more Akatsuki.
And stock supplies.
Oh, nice.
Here we go.
More capsule capacity.
Can I sell the ones that I have?
And maybe we should get another coin exchanger.
Wait, that's huge.
Let's get another shelf.
And I wonder if we can sell the ones that we have.
Wait, I think it was, right?
Where you take the...
Hold on.
Inspect.
Wait, no.
Oh.
Uh-oh.
I'm running out of posters.
Anime poster?
Ah, yeah.
More...
Um...
Naruto.
Didn't they give you... Is it this one?
Is this where I can sell it?
Hold on.
I have to figure out how I can take them out of the
move?
If I move it,
does it...
You know, does it give me back... Or, I don't know.
Oh, look at these!
These are all individuals, so I can move them around as I
please.
Hmm.
Move it to the yellow store, but empty it first.
That's what I'm trying to figure out is how...
Oh, take capsule.
There we go.
Oh, hmm.
Okay, here we go.
Here we go.
We can take them out.
Oh, there are no capsules in this machine.
Okay.
Okay, cool.
Now take you.
Move.
Now we're not going to sell all of them, but we'll slowly...
Oh, okay, okay.
Awesome.
We get half the prize.
Sure, sure, sure.
We'll slowly start moving them.
How much money do I get for this anyway?
How much?
Oh, 1200.
Okay.
And how much are...
How much are the new ones?
New ones are 5,000.
Okay.
Woo!
It's worth it, though.
It's worth it, I think.
Oh, you can even tell they look newer.
They're, like, shiny.
They look new.
We also need new ones.
Like, we'll start putting some over here as well.
Um...
Let's move Akatsuki to here.
Pixel Cat up here.
And we'll do another shelf here.
Oh, shoot.
We can't.
No.
Okay, hold on.
Gosh, being a store owner is tough.
Wait, hold on.
All right, cool, cool, cool.
Up there.
There.
and there okay all right all right we're making it work baby
we're making it work
machine is full
oh the coin exchange the coin exchanger we can do it like
now we won't have to do it that's huge
yes refill the storage how do I do that
oh okay okay let's move this over here trust the process
exactly exactly you're the horse all right mystic spellbound
this is our big hitter right here guys oh machine is full
and for how much we'll do 850 nice the process is trusted
yes yes and a little poster too oh no I didn't get the
poster yet that's fine okay oh wait I need more I'm silly
alright and let's add some stuff here you here how much are
you 90 no wait oh yeah these ones I think we don't have to
do like rent like round up or anything so we can do one 200
and you how much not 200 okay and you let me guess 99 no 200
oh More Raiders!
Thank you!
Hello, hello!
Welcome in.
I'm being an amazing shrewd businesswoman.
Isn't that right, everybody?
Isn't that right?
Rest in Glitchface, thank you!
Jack of Raid.
Thank you, welcome!
Make a gift too, thank you!
Alright!
Let's close- Oh, I forgot to go to the!
Robot fighting.
Thargo, thank you.
All right.
Let's pay my bills.
Look at this.
Five stars all around.
What is my...
Wait, did I repair everything?
Actually, I'm not quite sure.
We can renovate.
No.
Don't buy the wall, Squirrels.
Or don't buy the walls.
It's a scam.
What was I going to do?
Oh, my rating.
We're at four and a half stars, you guys.
It's crazy.
All right, let me make sure I repaired all these.
I think so.
Well, these are brand new, so.
Oh, float machine is fully repaired.
Perfect.
Start the day.
Yeah!
Oh, look how fast.
Full our store looks so far, you guys.
Hello!
Hello, hello!
Yeah!
Look at our brand new machine.
Oh, wait, I forgot to try for this.
There he is, isn't it?
He's using it.
That saves me time.
Let's do it while we're like here.
Why not?
Oh!
Open fast.
Metal.
Uh.
Common plastic.
Rare plastic?
Why is that one?
This is terrifying.
Uh, uh, thank you for buying bananas.
Thank you.
I guess this owl already.
What?
There we go.
I could have sworn I refilled this up.
It's been so much fun watching you play this mid.
You seem to have a lot of fun with these small business
games.
It's because it's so business savvy.
Nick, you!
I'm glad you have fun with them.
I have fun with them too.
I have fun playing with them.
They're so goofy.
Oh, package is empty.
I was hoping I could...
You know...
I was hoping I could keep the box so I could fill the box up
rather than my hands when trying to move things over, right?
I'm a girl boss!
Nice.
Yes.
Wait, did I have more things?
Oh, I did.
I did.
We can put up Dressini for 3,500 yen.
Crazy, crazy.
It's so popular.
It's so uncommon.
Oh, yes.
Oh, my God.
Oh, sorry.
I thought that was a really expensive one.
I thought that was...
Both of them.
Okay.
In demand.
Bowing at me.
Ghost light.
Ghost keep.
Ghost boy.
always that is what that is how we do it that is how we do
it she's a full figurine I'm gonna put her at 500 yen and
you at 500 yen common or not you are okay cool all right
cool let's see let's do an ad Let's do an ad.
It's a little late, but that's okay.
It's fine, probably.
I only missed a little bit of it.
And let's do decorate.
I thought I bought this, no?
This Mystic Spellbound poster?
Is it not out here?
Where did I put it?
What's the bat for?
For people that steal from me.
Oh, it's up here.
That's where I put it.
Condition.
Even this can break?
Why is it so cheap?
Oh, wait.
Who are you?
Wait, who are you?
Wait, what is this?
Wait, what?
The Yakuza!
The Yakuza are scaring me!
I'll be back!
Oh my god!
He broke my machine!
That's what these are for!
Oh my god!
Colonel Sanders is the Yakuza!
I mean...
They don't call him Colonel for nothing.
Holy cow!
They vandalized my store!
Why didn't we call... why couldn't we call the police?
What was that?
That was craziness.
That was absolutely bonkers.
Not because I had to go bonking them.
Oh, whoops.
11 herbs and spices.
It's Kentucky Fried Crime.
Ashiba's out.
Coin storage is full.
For what?
Wait, for the new thing?
Holy cow, that's popular.
Holy cow, is that popular?
a little pricey what are you talking about it's a coin
exchange how can it be pricey it's one to one you know i
think you're gonna have to get kick good and do punch punch
and clean up akiba that's what i'm this is why we're doing
the punch punch hey kid don't spend it all in one place now
you hear i thought he was gonna go straight for the sexy
anime girl figure
what exactly did that ad say i know banana bunch isn't here
yes it is yes it is it's definitely here it's here it's here
banana bunch is absolutely here banana bunch is right there
it's also outside no it's not don't give me a bad rating is
it my fault that things are out of stock blame the customers
blame everybody purchasing it
everybody loves banana bunch everybody loves banana bunch oh
yeah you should buy one of those she literally walked up and
then moon walked out she walked up saw the price and went
this kid cannot be pleased what's your deal buddy what's
your deal little man
what a fair price is you're 10 years old
stop purchasing stuff customers wait oh wait oops
oh yeah this kid oh she's
like i saw this in the window one day and i've been saving
up my whole allowance for it it's yours it's yours it's all
yours my favorite customer
Yes!
My favorite customer, baby!
Holy cow!
You get something nice out in there?
Wait, did you get anything in there at all?
Hey, buddy, we're closed.
Unless you're gonna buy something.
Just just Just loops it on out.
That's great.
He did the full turnaround.
Do you have a full 180?
All right.
Very nice.
Nice.
I think we can now order some other machines.
That aren't stinky machines.
And some maybe just more machines in general.
Maybe.
Oops.
That's not what I meant to do.
I wonder actually if I take this.
And then do this.
Oh I can only add.
Dang it.
I thought I could put some too.
You got a good amount of funds.
Yeah we did.
all right no capsules I have the right idea dang it is it
because my thing was too full the box was too full
hmm yeah we're making crazy dollars crazy yen all right
we're gonna get we're gonna replace this whole top row
actually what if I put them out here instead.
Wait, what if I put them out here instead of like selling
them and make even more money?
Anyway, let's buy three more.
Uh, and then buy, and then what all do we need here?
These guys are pretty dang popular.
These mystic spellbounds.
We need more of those.
like three quarters we'll do another another banana banana
bunch
another Aegis nice wait what do you mean I wasted money how
did I waste money I don't waste any money I'm making I'm
making money.
I'm making money, baby.
I'll just put it out here for now.
You sold one of the new machines.
Wait, I did?
No, I didn't.
Did I?
How did I...
Wait, no?
Wait, I did?
No!
Oops.
Oh well.
Whoopsie poopsie.
This is why I shouldn't be selling them at all.
I should just be moving them out there.
What do you worry?
Oh well.
It happens.
Not the end of the world.
That's business.
You gotta spend money to make money.
any.
These ones are pretty popular too so we'll put that in
there.
Sheeb.
Wait, did I order more sheep?
No.
More mystic spellbound.
Alright.
Very nice.
Stop fighting!
You?
And then...
Oh, we have another one out here.
Put some mystic spellbound in there.
Nice.
Okay.
We have, let's, let's do some polls.
Let's do a banan, banan, banan poll.
What?
Wait, but it says it's common, but it's gold.
Wait, am I getting the same one?
Wait, how?
do i even try again what the hell was that
what was that oh my god
even though i only did like five pulls It took it out the
machine so much.
All right.
Close the shutters.
SSR, Cobb, and Pole.
What the heck?
Did you pet the cats?
I've been petting the cats.
I'm petting the cats.
I need to pet them more.
Naruto.
Oh my god.
Kitties, kitties.
Why are you running into my store?
All right.
where's my other cat there you are there we go okay all
right we're gonna start the day we're gonna do an ad boom
bam bam bam thank you ma'am and let's sell sell come on in
yes welcome welcome you're looking awfully hot today does
that harassment if i say that no i think they i think i
think they she would want to be said hot called hot oh my
god she immediate hey hey viral tick-tock post wait that
lady just walked off with my
oh holy cow things are selling things are flying off the
shelves Didn't I just refill these?
Holy cow, things are flying off the shelves.
What the hell is happening?
Bananya, bananya.
Hey, move?
Have I been misjudging the people this entire time?
Have they been actually going to pay, but I attack them?
Oh no, I'm out of sheaves.
Oh no, I'm out of sheave.
Let's order.
Does fast sheave order?
And we got knee-bun bites!
People are looking for this.
Sheave.
Wait.
Oh, machine is full.
Never mind.
Okay, alright.
Yeah, we got miniature foods, baby.
awesome sauce excuse me gotta collect my cash when can I get
the magnet I'm guessing the magnet allows me to like collect
money automatically which would be sick be really awesome
like when I say awesome sauce wait see it is you see it
there wait renovate we can make a bigger store wait uh is it
stock supplies no is it oh it's i think it's advanced tools
level 20 you can pick up from the workbench and this will
allow you to collect coins from a distance yeah dang
eventually hopefully
shall we do a viral tick-tock post wait what is this oh yes
let's do stock supplies two more And then also A TikTok ad
Wait, we'll do the TikTok ad tomorrow It's already 2pm
Rotate It's already 2pm We don't need that
Which is good?
What's full?
Give me the cash?
Give me the money?
Owner attacked me at the register I didn't know such thing I
did no such thing Where are you at?
These are worth 550.
Where's my cat?
I pet you.
I love you.
I haven't had a chance to even look outside.
Oh no, the K-pop's are here.
No.
I haven't had a chance to even look outside.
Bad boys, bad boys.
Oh, bad boys, bad boys.
Oh, yeah, but I don't pay for song rights.
Bad boys, bad boys.
Wait, can I please repair this machine?
Oh my god.
Wait, what are they saying?
Reasonable?
Yeah, there we go, there we go, there we go.
All right.
Fully repaired.
Collect the cash.
Oh, you're back?
You're back?
They love it here.
Yes!
Why are you guys being so feral and strange?
What's this?
Oh.
Thank you.
Because they're cats.
That's not any excuse.
Oh, yeah.
oh yeah guys we're right oh the cash is flowing this is
crazy i think i only have eight left yeah that was it we
gotta order somewhere we gotta order we gotta go go go wait
we have 12 more decorations oh the nippon bites are so cute
the miniature food
cats aren't always mean to each other wait uh we were doing
mystic spellbound oops
thank you thank you you can hire a worker wait can we
finally hire a worker who would be even higher who is who is
dedicated to the job Who do we feel can...
Take a... take a... pick up the...
Oh, I have one left.
Let's go.
Pick up the torch.
We need Hatsune Miku.
Wait, okay, there we go.
I like how cats just roam my store.
It's really enjoyable.
I'll be doing wonderfully.
Hi Brendan!
You got this!
Good luck with everything.
I'm cheering you on!
Oh, coin stock.
Take that.
Coins, coins, coins.
Oh, okay.
Wait, did someone... did someone buy this?
Maybe someone grabbed it.
They haven't checked out yet.
Uncommon plastic banana for 700 yen.
750 yen.
Everybody needs an uncommon plastic banana.
Everyone has uncommon plastic banana.
Everybody loves uncommon plastic banana.
Perfect!
Yeah!
Yes, perfect!
put the coins in the slots perfect oh so perfect the coins
the money in the slide yes yes the money in the slot wow so
many so many oh wow actually the bananas went crazy you guys
so many rates today thank you thank you thank you must think
that's face thank you thank you thank you Add the car.
Maybe we do another Nippon bites.
Two of them.
Bye.
Dorgo, thank you.
Yeah, lots of raids today.
Oh yeah, oh yeah.
Oh good.
I didn't realize this was empty.
Maybe we do a third one then.
I think we should.
Oh, nope.
Well, that's fine.
I think someone will... Oh, wait.
Maybe I didn't replace the other banana.
Super liminal.
Thank you for the gifted.
It's all coming up, Minto.
Oh, yeah.
I think I just saw the blue-haired girl from Star Ocean
until the end of time walking down the street.
You're delusional?
You're delusional.
There's not a single person here with blue hair.
It's all in your head.
It's all...
Oh, we ran out of Sheeb, too.
Ah, well, thank you.
Awesome.
Let's order some more Sheeb.
One Punch Man also never visited.
That guy!
That guy actually hates us maybe all right let's see we've
got some new stuff huh i don't want any of the abstract
stuff okay we can get a new anime at level eight
oh macho
don't never give up more cars you think i'm buying too many
posters you guys be honest You think I'm buying too many
posters.
Look at that.
That guy looks goofy as hell.
Thinks a lot of me, though.
Of course.
Never enough.
Oh, giant Sakura tree.
We need two of them.
When... Oh, level 10.
I was like, when can I get the new Tokyo poster?
I think I got more Sheeb stuff.
oh they're so small I thought they'd be crazy big for some
reason you know to like fit the vibe let's do this we can do
this and then like have little cat underneath it what oh
yeah there he is no no
there he is a little cat frolic in through the cherry
blossom so cute so precious car.
And also, never give up!
I'm running out of...
Oh, wait.
Akatsuki Cloud could go here for sure.
Akira noida!
There we go, yeah.
This is looking sick, you guys.
What did I get?
Oh, Sheeb.
nice and is there any more out here nice
we should get more of those more nippon bites oh my gosh
this is exhausting you guys running a business I'm like just
too good at it and then I maybe we should hire some staff I
love Level six!
Oh, not, not yet, not yet.
Robot gambling, you know it.
We'll do that right after I finish restocking everything,
making sure everything's good.
And stocked.
Okay.
All right.
I guess I'll have to get more Aegis Framed stuff too.
Okay.
Oh my goodness.
Goodness!
Okay.
More Aegis Frame.
More Mystic.
Whatever.
Whatever it's called.
Mystic Spellbound.
Holy cow.
Ah!
I'm almost level 6 now?
Am I?
Oh yeah, I'm level 5.
Awesome.
What we can do...
I didn't even see that one.
Holy cow.
Oh.
What we can do is pull some more gotcha.
I think that also like makes it so we gain more level stuff.
So cool.
Okay.
Let's do more mystic spellbound.
Auto pull.
Yes.
Also, we got a thing to make our shop bigger.
How many times am I going to get this dang girl?
What can I?
Again.
Oh, you're new.
Oh, bloomers.
I've heard that figure sculptors actually like when people
look up the skirts because they spend a lot of time
sculpting every aspect of the figure.
And typically that's a part that's not very commonly seen.
You know what I mean?
So they appreciate it.
So says, Mr. Stewart.
I think I'll buy another box, actually.
Well, no, it's okay.
Good thing I always do that.
Me too.
I'm appreciating the art.
Oh, I didn't.
Oh, my gosh, I didn't repair these yet.
Oh my gosh, there's too much to do.
And sometimes it's a really awesome...
It's a really awesome, like, surprise, you know?
You never know.
It could be white, or it could be shimapan, or it could be
ruffly.
It's good to check.
We look as a courtesy.
Yeah!
It was art appreciation homework, mom.
Yeah.
I'm appreciating the art.
So, next time you look up, you upskirt your figure and you
think, ah, man, is this strange?
No, because the sculptors sculpted that part.
If they didn't want you to look, they would have Just like
filled it in, you know?
They would have just filled it in.
You would have never been able to check to begin with.
And we're all art appreciators here?
Taking notes?
Absolutely.
Absolutely!
Wait, can I also put stuff...
Wait, what did I just do?
Where did that go?
Wait.
Did I just discover the entrance to the back rooms?
Okay, guys, here I go.
That was weird.
Let's go to Robot Fight Club.
Can we go to the club?
What took you so long?
What?
all right who we got today who do we have today place oh we
could do three of them rivet i love rivet all in on rivet
fight fight rivet rivet oh rivet rivet you take these you
take yeah rivet Yes!
Yes!
It's okay, you can take a few!
Yeah, yeah, just one more!
Yeah!
Nice.
Robot Fight Club is awesome.
Guys, it's time for Crank.
Crank!
Tonight's your night!
You had a bad night the other night, but that's okay.
You can take this, you can take... You can...
around yes yes yes oh my god crank is going insane oh so
spark come on crank yes
again i'm all i'm rivets biggest fan if they're a rivet
rivet is literally like i have posters of rivet in my room
rivet keep dodging keep dodging oof okay this is a close
match you guys.
Rivet?
Rivet.
I bet everything on...
Rivet!
I'm that guy right there.
I've lost it all!
Get me out of here, man.
I just want to go.
I just want...
...
I'm never going to recover.
Real and true that the best statues are like that for you to
see.
Yes, that's what I'm saying.
Any cats in here?
Well, four
stars.
Got Chibi Shibra series.
Happy with it.
Found Aegis Frame series.
Exactly what I wanted.
Great.
Then why did you rate me four stars?
Why?
Exactly what I...
Why did you rate me three stars?
If you got exactly what you wanted.
I'm supplying you the goods.
Kitties, kitties.
So picky.
So stinking picky.
Japanese are tough with their five star.
They actually are.
They are extremely...
Oh, wait, what is...
I found the back rooms again?
They're extremely...
tough with their okay we're gonna reduce some of these
pricing try and move some inventory here trying to remove
some inventory here
all right tabelog is no joke I mean that's what I mean we'll
do 150 150 150 150 all right 150 nobody wants these dang
birds nobody wants these stinking birds all right let's open
the day let's do a tick tock ad and i mean we could do both
oh you can't run multiple ads just kidding i said we could
do And I lied to you all.
If you guys have never been to a Japanese, like, like, I
guess, you know, if you're a guy shopping at, like, you
know, clothing stores, maybe you haven't been to a ladies'
clothing store.
But the girls will be, like, they will sound exactly like
that.
They'll be like, you know, I don't know.
It's like they are plugging their nose.
Is anyone buying stuff?
You guys gotta buy stuff.
Or else I'm gonna go broke.
And this place will shut down.
And you'll never get gotcha again in your life.
Nasal greeting.
It's true.
I'm not even exaggerating.
Even a fraction.
I am being 100%...
Sincere.
Dang, banana really took off.
My rating went down.
How?
Oh, she took that bird.
She took that bird.
Oh, she took the figure.
Nice, nice, nice.
Reducing the prices.
Did it.
It did it.
Feather frenzy isn't there.
Oh, shoot, wait.
Do I only have one feather frenzy machine?
Where do all my feather frenzies go?
Uh-oh.
Wait.
I don't have a machine at all!
Don't worry, sir!
Uh-oh.
Feather Frenzy is coming back.
Feather Frenzy is back on the menu, everybody.
Oh, shoot.
I had no idea.
I didn't even have a single one.
Shoot.
That's pretty bad.
I was like, I'm not moving any of this stock.
No wonder why.
You would think about creating your own line of capsules for
an online gotcha.
I don't know, maybe.
I feel like though realistically it would be so expensive
like the gotchas themselves would end up being so expensive
you know what I mean we gotta get more shape out here yes
yes thank you
okay alright hopefully that guy doesn't give us oh my gosh
wait oh that's not what I meant to do but that's fine
feather frenzy people What?
Feather Frenzy?
They sold out instantly!
Yeah, it would be a lot of figures, right?
I don't know.
It'd be fun to try it, but...
Um...
Nice.
Oh, hello.
Sorry about that.
Oh my gosh, you got the banana!
Oops.
7.50.
Yes.
It really is Feather Frenzy.
Yeah, they're like going crazy for it.
little expensive what are we talking about that's the
feather frenzy our uncommon yeah yeah our uncommon yeah yeah
nice nice nice yes nice one man's trash oh what's that she
is another man's treasure they're flocking they're going
feather feather fanatic feather crazy no rather feather
frenzy just as the name applies implies this this crazed
this new hit toy is making the the customers go fanatic it's
a feather frenzy thank you very much we can make our place
bigger now maybe we do that oh first expansion more space
more potential oh please don't mind the mess oh my gosh oh i
have to spell words again please don't mind the mess bless
this mess bless this mess oh my god wait a second i didn't
know would bless this mess bless this mess
oh my gosh oh my gosh oh my gosh we got gca before
before uh feather frenzy two before feather frenzy volume
two we got gca it's kind of random like what things go what
people go bonkers over you know we leveled up we could get
iry and we got a new retro console drop wait that's sick
that's awesome yeah good job kitty good job employee let's
hire hire staff She has, like, not very many skill at all,
but she's gonna be great.
I know it.
I want to order the new one.
This one.
Whoa!
Oh, okay.
Never mind.
I thought it was kind of expensive at first, but...
And then...
Oh, wait.
I didn't actually order it.
Let's get, like, four more of these.
Okay.
All right All right, where's our girl?
Irie.
Oh, Irie, I'm gonna assign you Talk a sign to refill
actually assigned to repair Repair is something that like I
kind of don't think about you know what I mean Because it's
like kind of
I'm like busy repair or refilling like I can see when
something needs when money needs to be collected and I could
smell when money needs to be collected, but I can't see when
something needs to be repaired.
What did they say?
My shift is over.
What are you talking?
Irie, you bitch.
I'm firing you tomorrow.
My machine is broken.
That was your job.
Just got here.
I just hired you.
Do you think she'll be like, like a real retro rewind person
where I can oh wait I it's fine whatever where she'll do
stuff at the beginning of the day I guess I won't repair
anything and we'll see we'll find out what a slacker if I
have to pay for her no way if I have to pay for her day
today I'm gonna be I'm gonna be pissed I'm gonna be pissed
oh I can't get back here
thanks for the pay boss I'm out of here we're so generous
we're so stinking generous
okay nice oh yeah she gets sick and comes in with a mustache
I won't be able to stop laughing take it easy on the helper
girl she seems nice and she means well Well, give her a
chance.
She's got qualities.
Oh, whoops.
We should try some of these bad boys here.
Our little Nippon Bites or whatever.
Yeah.
Wow, it's really roomy in here now.
Actually.
Also, how do you read this?
Do you read it as late?
Or...
Laga.
Laga Didi.
Laga Daiga.
Oh, we're out of everything.
Wow.
Okay.
Kitties, kitties.
Let's order a ton of stuff.
Like, let's go bonkers with it.
Let's go absolute... Wait, did I order retro drop?
I think I did.
Let's order some more.
Nippon Bites 2.
Mystic Spellbound 2.
Feather Frenzy 2.
Sheeb 3.
Banana Bunch 2.
Aegis 2.
Oh, here they are.
Oh, wait.
There were more.
My bad.
I can't believe she left.
She literally left me.
She left me like this is my business or something.
She was like, see you next, see you tomorrow.
No, there is no tomorrow, Irie.
There is no tomorrow.
Feather frenzy.
Hag AC.
That's good.
Mystic Spellbound.
These are usually five.
500 so we'll do 600 instead oh we're gonna try for these
ones for sure though they're so cute they're so stinking
cute i
mean those black company what do you mean i hired her and
she left immediately how am i the how am i in the wrong here
how am i the black company here i said hey welcome to your
first day on the job and she said see ya how am i in the
wrong Small business owners have rights!
Small business owners have rights!
Honestly, I'm just gonna fill these up with the retro ones.
I'm just gonna fill them all the way up.
What's this?
Banana.
Actually, because banana's been pretty popular too.
We'll do another banana.
Retro drop.
Yeah.
Oh, is it really?
Are all these full?
Nice.
Banana.
The A and Aegis is silent.
It's pronounced Aegis.
It's Greek for shield.
Oh.
Aegis.
Oh, that's a banana.
Thank you, though.
The smallest business owner.
I know I just started today.
I just started today.
Like they're trying to run me out of business.
As soon as I get my footing.
This is messed up this cruel world.
This cruel, cruel world.
Dang, I got a lot of these retro drops, didn't I?
awesome feather frenzy oh shoot
awesome all right we went like crazy style we are not gonna
run out of anything now it's awesome did i restock stuff out
here though more retro
Did I just stock up stuff out here?
No.
This box is not empty.
Oh, there we go.
Good to be prepared, yeah.
Oh!
I was running on autopilot.
There's three in there.
time to dumpster dive yeah I just threw it in there just
pull them out
oh we'll get one for now it's okay me though I pay for that
box be buddy I appreciate you I think it costs a little bit
more than that and I'm not asking for more I'm just saying I
think it costs a little bit Wait a second.
I only lost 50.
Oh, thank goodness.
Oh, I thought it was a full 100.
Okay, we're fine.
We're fine, everybody.
We're fine.
It was just 50.
Oh, thank goodness.
Thank goodness.
Hold on.
I'm checking everything outside.
All right.
Just 50.
Let me cope.
all right we're not gonna fix anything and the hopes that
she will fix in the morning i can't even i'm not going to
the club i'm too sad i'm gonna be i'm gonna be sad i'm gonna
be sad slow dancing at the club i can't be sad in the club i
can't be crying in the club i i won't pay for you i'm sorry
next day you didn't do anything
good morning iri waiting
for the store oh she will actually not you know what i miss
ryan ryan worked before his shift what do you do you just
stand outside the door this is way realistic this is so
realistic Hiree, you start now!
Your day starts now!
Wait, please fix this, okay.
Hiree!
This shift has begun.
You've never heard of...
You can't just go to the store and it be...
And you can't just show up when it first opens.
And think that's when your shift starts.
No, it starts right before it opens.
Because you have to have time to set up.
She doesn't believe in overtime.
It's not overtime.
Irie.
Irie, you're on thin ice, baby girl.
You're on thin ice.
I'm a black company Well I make profits You'll see results
from my company You think that I just Fill these machines
and And just Let it be Let everything go No No I'm She
really is just standing there no I make things I make the
magic happen all right I think everything's good oh let's
stock this real quick we'll do we'll do another of her oh we
have another one here too we'll do you for how much 400 nice
ruthless business everything is fixed
one's not.
That was just used.
It's at 92 condition now.
What are you gonna do about it?
Where'd she go?
Irene?
Irene.
Are you on the phone?
Okay, she's working.
She's working, guys.
She's working.
Oh, shoot.
Uh, uh, uh, TikTok ad!
TikTok ad!
It's okay.
We are only hour late we're only an hour late we get we got
this let's do dreams let's change the soundtrack up a little
bit right my
dreams are crushed oh you want that guy you're
free to go
it's already begun everybody mint has become the sexy filthy
boss
handle I don't I reject the sexy logo or label I am only the
filthy boss every brings in customers she has a sort of
charisma a magnetic personality yeah I see it I see it
absolutely oh I forgot to pull some of these shall we do it
now Excuse me, everybody.
Well, open fast.
Oh, rare plastic.
More rare plastic.
Oh, common plastic.
Wait, uh, uh, guys?
Guys?
I'm lost in...
I was lost in the void?
She's just constantly screwing.
She's...
It's just constantly screwing.
Very good.
Yeah, Irie, you have to earn your money.
You have to earn your keep.
Keep screwing.
Keep doing it.
Yes.
Use that screwdriver.
Uh, ooh.
How much is this?
nice and we'll do another one even
a little pricey they say they have no idea they have no idea
hope you're having fun with the gacha pond thanks peasant
norm oh we need some more bananas more naners banyan I got
you I got you um everything is still oh feather frenzy I'm
running in circles yes yes earn your keep Irie keep screwing
keep screwing don't stop the machines are always broken
she's gonna have dreams about like what are you doing his
footsteps are hey hey wrong thing oh my god get out of oh my
god everything is Irie are we we got work to do oh my god
Irie oh my gosh our machines are too fragile for the He was
humongous.
I'm fixing like, uh...
So we can at least still have one game of each thing, you
know?
Oh my gosh.
Our rating is plummeting, guys.
We're losing...
We're losing everything.
Oh, customer's waiting.
Hello?
Uh...
You do know we have a machine for this.
this right?
RETRO, RETRO, RETRO, RETRO, RETRO, RETRO, RETRO, RETRO,
RETRO,
nice.
Delivering some cookies so you don't go hungry on the job!
Thank you, Eric!
Thank you!
Oh, Nippon Bites, Nippon Bites!
Everything is out of stock!
Everything's out of stock!
Okay, nice.
Customer waiting?
Oh.
Yes.
400.
She wants the fig- Yes, the figures!
Yes!
Take the fig- Yes!
This one was an expensive one!
Nice.
Alright.
Taking the cash.
Take it the cash.
Oh, another customer waiting.
Yes!
All right!
Oh, yes!
I knew putting both of those out was going to be good.
I knew putting those out!
Oh, yes?
Oh, that's it?
Okay.
I knew putting those out would be a good...
Oh, we need...
Eagress.
We guess, we guess, we guess, we guess, we guess, we guess,
we guess, we guess, we guess, we guess, we guess, we guess,
we guess, we guess, we guess, we guess, we guess.
Oh, my box is empty.
She's like, I'm out.
I'm out.
Don't ever ask me to do anything here ever again.
Oh.
Hopefully he wasn't waiting for too long.
Weeges.
Wow, we ran out of almost...
Well, I lost also almost all of it, too.
I lost a lot of money.
Today was pretty tough, you guys.
Today was not so great, huh?
We...
We lost so many machines.
Our rating plummeted.
Today was tough.
Yeah, that Sumo wrecked the place.
Oh.
I think I'm gonna have to keep Iry.
Otherwise...
Otherwise, we're screwed.
If another sumo comes in.
Banana.
We did make a good amount of money though.
Let's go.
At least she didn't ask for a raise.
That's so true.
She's a simple girl.
She doesn't know what she's worth.
I also won't pay her it.
that's also a life lesson.
She won't make what she's worth until she realizes and asks
for it.
That's just...
That's just life, baby.
That is life.
Does that have a magic spellbound on here?
I do.
Ain't that just the way?
We get We goes.
We goes.
Nice.
Um.
We should pull some other stuff.
Let's see.
What do we have?
Game gone.
Suggested.
I'll do 1000.
Nice.
We got some stuff we could put up.
What did we put?
What did he charge these for?
400?
Uh.
yeah 400 350 yes hurt ghosts hurt people it's true it's true
it's three it's 350 and it's it's true this is new gotcha
shop with a crazy stick wielding shop owner you will get
hurt you will get hurt if you come here you will get hurt
let's do one more day guys one more day and then we'll call
it we'll just order everything
these business expenses are getting crazier and crazier
thank you
crazier and they're just they're just they're rigging me dry
ringing me dry
all right feather frenzy i think i restocked everything so
we shouldn't have to so we'll do this and then we will um
repair then go to the fight club hang on oops i put it in
wrong spot.
Retro.
Awesome.
Repair.
Oh my gosh.
Wow, these are fully repaired.
Was Airee doing her job?
No.
Sakai Buu!
Sonna!
Oh my gosh.
All of these are actually pretty, like, high up.
This is pretty nice.
Wait, Airee is great.
She's a keeper.
Holy cow.
Wow, she was doing a great job.
She said she clocked out, but she was basically done.
Send me to the fight club.
I'm ready to lose it all.
A diamond in the rough.
She's quiet.
She doesn't say much, but...
There's only two today.
Crank.
I'm going to lose my wife.
I'm going to lose my kids.
I'm going to lose everything if you don't beat this, Crank.
Beat that.
Beat that pot.
You got this, Crank.
Crank.
It's all on you.
No pressure.
Crank.
I knew it would happen.
Alright, Spark, I need you to kill Crank.
Spark, it's all on you!
Crank is nothing!
Crank sucks nuts and bolts!
Crank is stupid!
Spark, you got this!
Beat Crank's metal booty!
You got this!
Spark!
Oh!
Yeah!
Punch him in the CPU!
You, yeah!
Ah.
Never gets easier.
Send me home.
Crank is washed.
Speed the kitties before we go to sleep.
Good night, kitties.
Let's do one more day.
I think we'll be able, we might be able to level up
tomorrow.
I don't know what we get once we level up.
Crank will remain.
this.
What if I stop?
What if I just don't pay her wages?
It does say bills will get paid automatically after seven
days, but what if I fire her after seven days?
Do I now have to pay the do I can I can I just you know what
I'll pay her okay wait I'll pay her I'll pay her the double
because we had to deal with the sumo she was on her phone
whoa whoa real japan capsule guys this is real japan capsule
what are you judging my store I don't want to hear it from
you kid this guy's always around here he's obsessed
waiting for the store to open waiting for you to come in
oops
Welcome!
Did I miss one?
I missed one.
Oh wow.
Pay and company stocks vested at 7 years prior to 6.
You better not go into the back and be on your phone.
them under their noses.
Ah!
Great pick!
Everybody loves banana.
Like, for real.
Oh, I don't have any figures.
Maybe we do some...
Let's do some banana pull.
We do fast?
Wow!
What is that?
Banana tactical!
Hello.
oh
wait worth way more wait no no no take it take it oh fine
whatever suggested
checking the machines yes checking the machines
we have a machine for this stupid customer the customer is
not always right guys being a business owner I've learned
this Especially when they are...
Remember in Retro Rewind?
They would be like, I'm sorry that I broke your thing.
I'll never break a thing again.
They were terrible.
The customer is not always right.
It's the first thing you learn in the biz.
The tough lessons.
Where?
Oh, I forgot my TikTok ad.
Oh my gosh.
I was like, where is everybody?
Oh no, we wasted so much time.
no we wasted we oh you it really makes a difference i'm
noticing that's crazy why can't i pet the cat more often
though in japanese the customer is king that's so true
that is very true
okay light yagami get out of here you're stinking up my shop
you're scaring the customers away wow dead it's a dead day
let's do some more banana gotcha so that we don't waste our
time here
banana kit rare metal duck it's business i swear honey i
don't know what achievement i just got for that we leveled
up we could get paper spirits collection license i don't
know what that means but i'm really excited about it wait
what does that mean is that a new thing what are they
are they oh it's like actually wait actual paper spirits
yeah metal duck solid oh i forgot to actually order it and
let's get some let's get four more of these oh i keep
forgetting to buy them.
Alright.
Awesome.
Slow day, huh?
Slow day.
Wait, what did that kid say?
A bit expensive.
No, no.
You're 10 years old.
You don't... Uh-oh.
Guys.
The K-pop.
Cover your ears.
Darmies.
Oh my god.
They're just dancing outside my streets.
Bad boys, bad boys.
Bad boys, bad boys, bad boys.
Wait, how much are...
900?
We'll do that much.
I'm collecting coins.
Alright.
Wegas.
No, that's not wegas.
Wegas, wegas, wegas, wegas, wegas.
Oh my god.
The K-Pops are literally just...
stepping on people.
They're walking everywhere.
They don't care about personal space at all.
They've never cared.
They're too popular.
Oh my god.
Whoa!
Twinning!
Hello?
I have a machine for this.
People like that, though.
I guess so.
What was that, banana?
Okay, we got a full storage thing.
Where is it?
Where's the full outside?
She's slowly but surely repairing things.
You're doing great, sweetie.
Shiva.
Excuse me.
I own this store, and I need to get in front of you.
I am, in fact, the owner.
and and such I
am in fact the one that is repairing this and and managing
this location holy stonks holy cow you guys
customer waiting what was what it was it i guess it was one
of the lady figures money money money
excuse me
all right let's put um let's put rare duck on here oh 5 000
yen we can sell it we can sell it for that we can sell it
for that wait what was our epic duck i mean epic epic banana
we could do like epic price though it's an epic rare how
could it only how could it be less than 5,000 the cat my
best customer probably wait did she leave oh oh I think she
left I
don't hear her screw in anymore I don't hear the sound of
her screwdriver the sweet sweet sound of machines being
repaired I
have all these boxes on the streets
nice i wasn't gonna put these in but now i'm thinking we
just do it anyway
let's put this back here um what's something that's really
popular what's something that's going crazy style right now
oh i'll just hold on i'll just we'll just wait for a second
um let's repair my gosh fully repaired hey there business
owner i'm in the insurance business and you should get some
insurance it would be a shame if a sumo got too rowdy in
there look if a sumo gets too rowdy in my place i've got iri
she's got my back she's gonna she'll take care of it she can
she's a mean
Machine screwing...
Machine.
And she will do it nicely.
She's a machine machine.
Nailed it.
Yeah, I did.
Look how much money I have.
You don't have your own successful gotcha shop.
The fact that I have this much money with these little
machines, this little amount of machines is kind of bonkers.
to me holy our coin was about to our coin machine was about
to break what new decorations do we have oh we do have I
don't think I got a retro one either or We're in Nippon
Bites.
Oops.
Why?
What else we got here?
Uh, wait, where is it for real?
Oh, here we go.
I just kept scrolling and nothing was happening.
Anime!
Ah, nothing.
No new clouds!
Food.
Oh, in stereo, I'm rooting for you.
these are so funny oh we really got nothing huh this kind of
sucks
this kind of sucks she's more of a machine than the robots
absolutely any more waves no not even a single wave we can
renovate apparently we got a new wall no new floor hmm Slim
pickens, huh?
Real slim pickens.
Let's do the gotcha shop OST again.
That one was nice.
Tokyo Street.
It's Tokyo Street eats license.
I want Go-Go Rainbow Heroes and Nyan-Yan Maid Cafe and
whatever Lumiere 4 is.
I need that.
Jurassic Frenzy!
Oh my god.
Dream B.
Wait, there's some crazy things in here, right?
Our shop is looking really awesome, huh?
Let's restock everything.
Oh, I didn't take all the money yet, either.
I'm slacking.
Okay.
Nippon Bites
Rolling for Ketzel Yeah, actually you can get Ketzel There
was a gotcha for Jurassic World and you could get I got the
Ketzel koalas, he's actually on my desk He's always on my
desk He's at my desk right now
So I do have a Ketzel, it was my first First pick too I have
him from So I do have a gotcha Ketzel funny yeah what are
these oh the posters
banana banana machine is full okay maybe banana is not as
popular anymore oh
yeah she got the pretzel yeah i got the pretzel
what did i not do she
Shebe and Weegis, I think.
If Toy Story is real life...
Oh, whoops.
What is the life of a gotcha toy?
Are they alive all trapped in the ball?
Waiting?
Imagine the 50 you sent to the landfill.
No!
Oh, I was like, wait a second.
What do you mean the 50 I sent to the landfill?
You mean in the game.
Yeah, I definitely did not.
But that was an accident.
Then that would be Toy Story...
What was it?
Toy Story 3?
they almost died in the landfill?
Didn't that, like, actually happen?
Yeah.
They did actually almost die in the landfill.
Crazy.
A little traumatic, maybe.
Let's get some more Weegis.
Wee, wee, wee,
What do we need, actually?
I think we need more...
More mystic spellbound as well.
Maybe I did fill this one up.
Yeah, I did, nice.
Oh, whoops.
Yeah, what does that mean for like figure statues, right?
Hmm.
Like figurines.
Does, is a figma alive?
According to Toy Story?
There was a gotcha alien in the first game from the claw
machine.
Huh?
Well, Kim?
Bo Peep was alive and she was part of a lamp?
That's so true!
She was just a lamp!
The paper spirits are so cute!
Let's pull for them.
Huge!
Cat.
Cute.
Very cute.
Huge!
Huge duck!
Duck or a Garmy?
What is that?
Oh, it's a Sheba.
I like when it's really dramatic.
Epic.
Epic duck.
Epic duck!
Whoa!
Gold unicorn!
Holy cow, our luck just then was crazy!
These...
Okay, these sheep also haven't dropped at all.
So let's do like 1,500.
Just keep dropping the price.
Nobody seems to want them anymore, sadly.
We'll drop her like 14.
Not that yet.
13, 50.
Yes.
Oh, there's a baby.
It's over like Labubus.
Oh, I saw a Labubu in the window of a store the other day,
and I was like, I couldn't, I could actually get this now.
I could actually purchase this now.
But people would think I'm lame-o.
They'd be like, oh my gosh, a Labubu in the second quarter
of 2026.
How embarrassing for you.
how many did you buy none i never got a little boo boo but i
actually kind of wanted one i'm part of the rare people that
think they're legitimately cute i wanted one not because of
the fad just because i thought they were kind of cute
looking because i loved where the wild things are um
actually it's q3 oh sorry have a Labubu t-shirt Uniqlo.
Oh, I saw those.
I saw those.
I combined Disney universe.
Wait, wait, I combined Disney.
Wait, oh, a combined Disney universe is kind of horrifying
when everything, even appliances, have human intelligence.
Watch a bug's life with their characters.
See the characters and Lion King scarfing bugs down.
I mean, well, yeah, human intelligence.
I was going to say, like, you know, ants are, bugs are still
living things.
You know what?
what you know what the Lion King said about that you know
what the Lion King said about that it's the circle of life
and it rules us all but a but but but but but but till we
find our way on the path of
It's the circle.
The circle of life.
Let's go beat up some robots.
Monkey D.
Luffy?
We can't even park.
I'm too fast, too furious.
They named that movie after me, by the way.
We got three.
this one doesn't even seem worth my time but sure bolt bolt
bolt bolt bolt bolt bolt bolt you're so sexy bolt you look
like chica you look like oh gosh i think oh it's over for
bolt no wait i'm gonna lose so much money no bolt please
please please please bolt the comeback please no no Please,
the comeback.
The comeback.
Me.
Me right now.
We can make back some of our buddy with Spark.
Fight.
Come on.
Kick pistons, little...
He can't...
He doesn't even have a face!
You have a face!
Yeah!
Alright.
Maybe I do need to do this last one.
so I can get more money.
All right, crank.
Crank!
Kick!
Oh, geez.
Oh, no, crank.
This is crank's flop era.
Oh, never mind!
Never mind!
Crank!
You are the best!
Go, Crank!
Yeah!
Did you see that one?
My, the goats never washed.
Yay!
Scar did nothing wrong what do you mean I mean the guy was
fine all right I am gonna change our I am okay we're doing a
little bit of remodeling oh wait renovating here we go oh
the planets are they planets
guys what is your favorite wall color do
you think the dev made the guy aspect of the game as an
excuse to justify the robot fight club I don't think you
need a reason to justify it no you guys say what number say
wall 7 wall 8 wall 4 say your favorite color why are you
saying mint that there's not even one that is a mint green a
lot of people saying seven are you trying to sabotage me oh
wait this kind of wait let's do the floors too oh never mind
we only have one option
everybody remember we are certified japan certified made in
japan 100 original oregano Premium quality certified product
of Japan.
Nippon.
Real Japan capsule.
Gotcha capsule shop.
They're real.
They've never...
This is one of the abstract arts.
Wait, is that a Gigo?
Oh no, sorry.
It's a Gogi.
And a Mega.
Revenge of Cybergirl.
Doraima.
Welcome to Akihabara.
Wait, let's listen to the Konbini sound.
It's so nostalgic, if you know, if you know you know, if you
know, you know.
will soon arrive on track number two for your safety please
stand behind the yellow line are you an idol group no what
are you promoting stop shaking oh it's a maid cafe i want to
see it i'm here muscle girl cafe where's your muscles flex
them for me i like the cats are
Can I go this way?
No, dang.
Anyone want a strong lemon after a hard day's work?
Thanks for the comfy stream.
Great way to end the weekend full of great news like your
video announcement and your upcoming outfit debut, July
15th, be there.
Be there.
Thank you guys so much for Akihabara Gacha Simulator
Thank you very much This was fun I hope you had fun too I'm
gonna go eat dinner O2 Mito
Thank you everybody.
Dorgo!
Thank you so much for that pig.
Thank you.
Cotton says voice acting, running a successful gotcha shop,
always making our days better.
And thank you for the five stars.
Thank you everybody.
Have a good day, have a good night, have a good time soon.
See you.
OTSKARESAMA!
OTSKARESAMA DESTA!
Thank you!
Bye-bye!
Bye-bye, bye-bye!
Wait.
I didn't- I didn't take off my glasses the entire time.
Break me?
Thank you!
Bye-bye!
Okay, thank you.